la grogne des salariés de la fonction
publique grève des perturbations demain
la coordination des infirmières en grève
le real peut forcer la négociation la
coordination des affaires mirent en
grève devrait amorcer la négociation en
direct de professeurs schwarzenberg
atterrissage manqué à rome contenant 22
blessés dans l'accident d'un boeing ou
gants dès le nobel de médecine à deux
américains et un britannique que vous
venez de voir pour la mise au point de
médicaments qui traitent plusieurs
maladies ouverture à bruxelles du procès
des jeunes britanniques qui avait
déclenché le drame du heysel en 85 ce
sont les titres de l'actualité ce soir
madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité a
beau être morose c'est un petit joyau
que nous vous offrons ce soir l'un des
tout premiers films de l'histoire du
cinéma un film tourné par georges méliès
en 1896 quelques mois après les images
historiques des frères lumière on
croyait que ce film avait disparu avec
une centaine d'autres
on l'a retrouvé en nouvelle-zélande la
petite fille de georges méliès qui a
consacré sa vie à rassembler les oeuvres
du premier cinéaste français l'a prêté à
virginie kirsch un peu de magie avec
michel pascal c'est georges méliès lui
même qui apparaît à droite de votre
écran et qui joue le propriétaire de ce
manoir du diable et c'est grâce à son
visage que le film a pu être
authentifiée par la petite-fille du
génial réalisateur transformation
escamotage apparitions et disparitions
avec fantômes chauve-souris et sorcières
le grand méliès qui fait ses débuts a
déjà tout inventé
il est le maître des trucages et nous ne
sommes qu'en 1897
georges méliès a tourné cinq cents films
comme celui ci dans son studio de
montreuil
on en a retrouvé 155 à ce jour et il
faut bien reconnaître que même look
assez spielberg doivent tout ou presque
à ce grand précurseur qui a fini dans la
misère
la grève des infirmières se poursuit
pour la troisième semaine consécutive la
coordination réunis cet après midi à
paris cherche à renouer le dialogue avec
le gouvernement tout en maintenant la
mobilisation des grévistes françoise
joly elles reconnaissent être épuisées
mais elles se disent calme et déterminé
c'est leur réponse aux propos de michel
rocard ce week-end le premier ministre a
attribué à 1
moment d'énervement leur refus aux
propositions du ministre de la santé
claude evin
consciente des risques d'essoufflement
de leur mouvement ce soir après douze
jours de grève les infirmières demandent
au gouvernement de réouvrir les
négociations sommes prêts si monsieur
rockeur et 20 nous invite dans une demi
heure
nous sommes prêts à retourner à matignon
au mythe heures d'attenté pour
rediscuter et nous il ya des garanties
qu'on doit obtenir immédiate et concrète
si on veut véritablement partir sur des
bases sereines et je crois que c'est le
motif pour lesquels la grève continue la
grève reconductible puisque pour
l'instant nous avons aucune garantie
sérieuse par rapport à nos
revendications nous sommes très loin du
compte et ça je crois qu'on leur demande
enfin l'entendre il faut payer pour se
faire entendre les infirmières
manifesteront à nouveau à paris et dans
les grandes villes de province samedi
prochain et les cadres infirmiers se
sont joints au mouvement lance
aujourd'hui un mot d'ordre de grève de
trois jours
devant tant d'effervescence d'inquiétude
sur l'avenir de la profession est aussi
de récriminations sur la condition même
d'infirmières comment de toute jeune
fille se prépare-t-elle à ce métier
ont-elles encore la vocation chantal
kimmerlin l'a vérifié aujourd'hui dans
une école d'infirmières à paris a été
reconduit massivement par un vote à
l'unanimité assemblée générale amphi
bondé grève depuis les premiers jours
les élèves infirmiers suivent leurs
aînés se bat pour une meilleure qualité
de la profession d'abord au niveau du
recrutement que nous soyons recruter un
niveau bac ou sinon un examen
d'équivalence on enlève le capuchon
le bisou conséquences du malaise l'école
de la salpêtrière à paris n'a pas fait
le plein à la dernière rentrée 200
places en première année 170 inscrits
seulement le métier n'attire plus autant
de candidats et la déception des élèves
et des enseignants gros si on demande
aux infirmiers d'être à la page d'être
toujours plus performant de toujours
toujours présent faut se mobiliser cccc
moralement c'est très épuisant et on se
rend compte que malheureusement le reste
ne suit pas on se retrouve dans des
services très peu nombreux
on s'épuise on se fatigue et le malade
en pâtit et c'est dommage moi qui est
fait c'est mes études dans cette même
école il ya presque trente ans il ya
trente ans exactement puisque 56 à 58
je crois que nous avions plus
précisément peut-être une sécurité que
les jeunes ne ressentent pas aujourd'hui
on est acquis à l'école inquiet pour
l'avenir les conditions de travail et le
futur salaire pourtant la vocation est
toujours là et pour la majorité des
élèves c'est elle qui est finalement
gagnante
on voit les gens rentrés malades qui
souffrent qui ressortent avec le sourire
qu'ils nous disent merci
je pense que même si financièrement n'a
peu de choses on a beaucoup en voyant
ces gens sortir avec le sourire
l'école c'est trois ans d'études après
le bac les élèves infirmiers ont fait un
choix en y entrant celui d'avoir à leurs
yeux amitié et un rôle essentiel dans la
société même si la grève reste plutôt
populaire on l'a vu ces derniers jours
auprès des médecins et aussi des malades
ça durait même ne peut qu'en rayé de
plus en plus le bon fonctionnement des
hôpitaux professeur schwarz bart bonsoir
vous l'êtes vous êtes un des très grands
patrons avoir soutenu cette grève depuis
le début à votre avis jusqu'à quand
cette grève peut-elle durer parce qu'il
faut bien arriver à comprendre c'est que
les infirmières souhaite qu'on les
reconnaisse comme ce qu'elles sont or
depuis une quinzaine d'années ces filles
ne sont plus des piqueuses ce sont des
techniciennes supérieur health à
surveiller des appareils de réanimation
poser des appareils de perfusion
surveiller ce qu'on appelle les
constantes des malades d'une façon telle
que ce sont devenus des auxiliaires des
médecins et elles veulent être reconnus
comme tels alors ça c'est l'une de leurs
revendications la principale
revendication mais alors est ce qu est
ce que ça veut dire professeur que pour
vous les revendications salariales sont
au second plan elles sont au second plan
mais je m'explique quand les infirmières
à rift à l'école elles ont une capacité
du baccalauréat
où elle passe un examen équivalent après
trois années d'études elle souhaite être
reconnu comme technicienne supérieure et
non pas comme un 10 et indiciaire à la
fonction publique
ce qui signifie que si on leur reconnaît
le brevet de technicien supérieur l
accepterons tout ce que le gouvernement
pourra leur proposer
et pourquoi ont-elles demandé 2000
francs parce que le salaire d'une
infirmière débutante et de 6000 francs
et que le salaire d'un technicien
supérieur ayant son bts et de 8000
points
d'où les cards de 1000 francs en réalité
lundi salariale est totalement dépendant
de la reconnaissance de leur peau de
leur profession alors est ce que ça veut
dire professeur que vous vous
soutiendriez cette grève jusqu'au bout
quelles que soient sa durée quels que
soient éventuellement l'amener à ce
qu'elle peut faire peser sur le
fonctionnement de vos services
madame vous m'avez demandé de venir
parler ce soir en tant que médecin et en
tant que personne qui soutient
fondamentalement profondément la grève
des infirmières je m'explique
elle souhaite aller jusqu'au bout non
seulement pour la reconnaissance de leur
métier mais aussi pour la reconnaissance
des droits aux malades si elles sont
tellement soutenus par la population
jusqu'ici car n'oubliez jamais qu aucun
malade n'a pâti de la grève des
infirmières tous les soins d'urgence ont
été assurés et ça ça peut continuer
quelle que soit la durée de la grève ça
a continué en grande bretagne comme vous
le savez une dame qui s'intitule la dame
de fer a dû céder ce qui se passe c'est
que les infirmières sont celles qui nous
aide à lutter pour la vie des malades et
les malades
le savent on ne peut pas oublier associé
à leur technicité à leurs compétences et
à leur efficacité leur dévouement ses
filles
ces jeunes femmes qui ont en plus une
fois le travail d'infirmière accompli à
l'hôpital des travaux de famille à
empire chez eux ces femmes représente
pour nous une grande partie de leurs de
la médecine et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la majorité des médecins
français les soutiennent et les
soutiendrons jusqu'à leur victoire
professeur schwarzenberg merci la cgt
vous le savez a déposé pour demain des
préavis de grèves dans différents
secteurs déjà il ya eu des perturbations
aujourd'hui dans les ptt aussi à nouveau
dans le rer
demain ce seront surtout les transports
en commun qui seront touchés dans leur
ensemble déjà à lyon aujourd'hui la
grève était totale
claude réjean une ville paralysée
les lyonnais ont vécu une fin de journée
très pénible dans des embouteillages
géants la grève des tcl la société des
transports en commun local a été très
largement suivi
le métro a dû fermer ses accès et seuls
40 autobus sur les 700 du réseau en
circuler il ne restait que le système d
pour les usagers en détresse la grève a
été menée par quatre syndicats pas de
coordination donc comme pour les
infirmières mais des revendications
salariales accrochante 15 cents à deux
mille francs mensuels pour tous le
retour à la normale est prévu pour
demain à lyon mais d'autres débrayages
et d'autres embouteillages sont attendus
dans le courant de la semaine
voyons maintenant comment s'organiser
pour demain une journée difficile à
paris et dans certaines villes de
province véronique auger
à paris ce sont les métros et les lignes
a et b du rer qui seront les plus
perturbés puisque le syndicat autonome a
également demandé des arrêts de travail
les perturbations les plus importantes
auront lieu aux heures de pointe
les autobus parisiens seront plus
régulier trois sur quatre mais c'est une
moyenne
certains dépôts fortement syndiquée à la
cgt risque d'être bloqué à 50 % en
province les transports urbains devrait
être ralentie à lyon montpellier
bordeaux et rennes les ptt prévoit un
retard dans le tri et la distribution du
courrier à paris d'après la cgt
76 service aurait déjà décidé la grève
enfin à la sncf sur les grandes lignes
peu de perturbations deux trains sur
trois vers l'ouest et vers toulouse
ailleurs pas de problèmes en banlieue
l'interconnexion à paris nord en
provenance de roissy est supprimé vers
l'est et vers le nord 1 train sur 3 à
saint lazare un sur deux justement
l'équipe de télématin sera à pied
d'oeuvre à saint lazare à partir de 6h45
du matin pour donner à tous ceux qui
habitent en région parisienne des
informations les plus précises sur ce
qui va rouler et sur ce qui ne rendra
pas entre tous ces conflits salariaux
qui vont affecter la fonction publique
surtout jeudi jour de grève générale
un lien commun ou plutôt une méthode qui
remonte à 1946 il s'agit de la grille
unique de rémunération qui est appliqué
à des métiers très différents et qui
pour suivre des évolutions diverses à
créer à la fois des rigidités et des
distorsions maryse mano christophe
martet derrière la grille des
fonctionnaires il y a huit millions de
salariés et retraités leur patron c'est
l'état les collectivités territoriales
ou les hôpitaux
leurs grilles de salaires date de la
libération et regroupe quatre grandes
catégories la catégorie à recrutent au
niveau minimum de la licence c'est le
haut du panier où l'on retrouve les
inspecteurs des impôts et les
professeurs du second degré en début de
carrière un professeur démarre à 7700
francs bruts et termine à 14 1800 francs
entre les deux onze échelons franchi en
33 ans de carrière sur le critère de
l'ancienneté la catégorie b regroupe le
tiers des fonctionnaires recrutés à
partir du baccalauréat
on trouve là les instituteurs et les
infirmières qui ont souvent le niveau 2
licence une infirmière débute à 5900
francs bruts et termine sa carrière à
9200 francs au bout de 25 ans d'activité
pas question de passer en catégorie à
l'équivalence des diplômes n'est pas
reconnu en fait tout le monde est
concerné les gens bien portants devoirs
sont concernés demain peuvent être
malades
c'est leur problème acier une autre
tiers des fonctionnaires se retrouve en
catégorie c niveau requis le bepc
c'est ici qu'on retrouve les préposés
des postes un facteur par exemple gagne
5000 francs bruts au départ et termine
27 ans plus tard à 6900 francs seuls les
concours internes peuvent lui donner
accès à la promotion sont pas de faire
des concours internes aux frais après
vingt-cinq ans d'ancienneté
on accède au grade de préposés chef avec
6137 francs bruts
enfin la catégorie des recrute son
diplôme des agents de service et de
bureaux c'est une minorité
les syndicats estiment que les
fonctionnaires ont perdu 1% de pouvoir
d'achat par an depuis 85 alors que les
salaires du privé ont augmenté de 0 4%
par an les pouvoirs publics eux conclut
au maintien du pouvoir d'achat des
fonctionnaires
si l'on inclut les promotions et
l'ancienneté le système est d'autant
plus compliquée que toutes sortes de
primes se greffe sur la grille si le
gouvernement et les syndicats
conviennent de la nécessité de la
réviser cette fameuse grille le problème
demeure de la méthode et de l'ampleur en
fonction des contraintes de la rigueur
je ne peux pas contester la position du
gouvernement a déclaré tout à l'heure m
en bas rhin radio monte carlo
il faut essayer d'atténuer le plus
possible les difficultés qui sont
insupportables mais s'il doit y avoir un
effort général de raison dans notre pays
pour que la croissance se poursuive a
dit l'ancien premier ministre
le bilan est lourd les dégâts au sol
impressionnant et le mystère ce soit
reste entier pourquoi ce boeing 707 de
la ligne aérienne ou landaise qui
reliait londres à rome s'est il écrasé
cette nuit à l'atterrissage sur la route
entre rome et l'aéroport
trente personnes sont mortes dominique
terres le pilote avait pourtant tout
tenté pour redresser l'appareil avant ce
hangar en vain l'ale du boeing 707 a
percuté de plein fouet
le bâtiment et c'était l'explosion comme
une bombe diront les témoins les
voitures stationnées ont pris feu sur
plus d'un kilomètre des débris de
carlingue
des corps déchiquetés des fauteuils
éventrée c'est dans cet amas de
ferraille que les enquêteurs recherchent
la précieuses boîtes noires qui
permettraient de comprendre les raisons
de l'accident
il semble d'ores et déjà certain que le
manque de visibilité soit en partie à
l'origine du drame
le pilote du boeing avait d'ailleurs
essayé à deux reprises de poser
l'appareil avant la catastrophe
version confirmée par la tour de
contrôle que c'était alors passé hier
soir sur la piste numéro 34
impossible de répondre pour l'instant
mais le ministre de l'intérieur antonio
gave heim était aujourd'hui l'hypothèse
d'un malentendu entre le pilote
hollandais et les aiguilleurs du ciel
italien un malentendu qui a provoqué la
mort de 30 personnes
bruxelles 29 mai 85 finale de la coupe
d'europe des champions au stade du
heysel
liverpool doit affronter la juventus de
turin une heure avant la rencontre la
bagarre éclate bilan 39 morts 450
blessés trois ans et demi plus tard le
procès commence sur le banc des accusés
24 supporters britanniques
deux officiers de gendarmerie et
l'ancien secrétaire général de l'union
belge de football à bruxelles
isabelle bechler drôle de 1re junior
elle a vu son audience chaotique
incident entre la défense et le
provenant vers linde entre la défense et
la partie civile qui représente les
victimes italiennes
les supporteurs de liverpool le étaient
calmes et attentifs suivant les débats
grâce à plusieurs interprètes sage comme
de bons élèves qui n'auraient jamais de
leur vie mériter le qualificatif de
hooligans zh
ils sont tous venus se tiennent très
bien je leur ai fait la morale je leur
ai dit qu'ils représentaient le club de
liverpool en quelque sorte même si le
club n'approuve pas tout à fait cela
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ils sont des ambassadeurs d'une certaine
manière et à ce titre il faut que tout
se passe bien qu'il se tienne comme des
gars responsable et que rien ne tourne à
l'aigre en fin de journée défendue par
l'ancien maire de leader pool d'avocats
travailliste de 80 ans qui a repris du
service pour cette rose
les hooligans sont en confiance au terme
de cette journée bien confuse certains
envisageaient de confiance bretagne dès
ce soir
et de revenir pour les premiers
interrogatoires la semaine prochaine si
on me dit de rester j'aurais si on me
dit de partir je pars mon avocat m'a dit
que je pouvais rentrer alors je vais y
aller on n'y comprend rien à cette
première journée un vrai désastre
première journée marquée par la
procédure l'humain c'est pour plus tard
et on y viendra
le procès doit durer six mois 26
britannique donc avaient été
formellement identifiés pour avoir
provoqué la bousculade mortelle 24/100
donc à bruxelles bien calme on vient de
voir libres de leurs mouvements
un autre est en prison dans son pays
pour d'autres méfaits le 26e restait
introuvable
philippe harrouard nous dit maintenant
comment on voit ce procès de londres à
liverpool comme dans toute la grande
bretagne on parle du procès mais la
presse adopte un profil bas à la
télévision on a mis l'accent sur tout
sur le triste sort des 26 inculpé trois
ans et demi de procédure
un procès qui va durer trois mois il
faut se loger à bruxelles une île cher
payer les avocats
or la plupart des accusés viennent de
famille modèle cette mère d'un inculpé
craint l'environnement hostile entourant
le procès il y aura dit elle
beaucoup d'italiens entendu comme témoin
leurs contacts avec les britanniques
risquent d'être explosives
deux des 26 supporter comparaissant à
bruxelles ne sont pas dans le box des
accusés il purge une peine de prison en
grande-bretagne pour autre chose
tous vont plaider non coupable ils ont
été identifiés par la police de
liverpool après visionnage des cassettes
de l'événement comme celui ci qui
reconnaît après coup que c'est bien lui
qui a été filmé mais dit-il
j'ai été attaqué par un supporter
italien je me suis donc défendu nous
espérons seulement en angleterre que
simplement et seulement que
la tradition de justice en belgique ça
existe n'est ce pas que ça se voie
pendant ce procès mais nous espérons
aussi que cette image assez atroce des
fans britanniques va diminuer ou même
disparaître maintenant dès maintenant un
procès qui fait mal à la fibre
patriotique
un autre procès s'est ouvert à bordeaux
aujourd'hui et c'est encore ce qu'on
embête le déroulement
le procès de deux chefs présumés de l'ex
effet l'insee félix tomasi et charles
pieri accusé d'avoir assassiné un
légionnaire et d'en avoir grièvement
blessé un autre en février 82 dominique
verdeilhan de journée où l'on a passé
plus de temps dans la salle des pas
perdus que l'on la salle d'audience pas
moins de cinq suspensions de séance pour
un procès tant attendu qui n'a en fait
toujours pas commencé
un procès attendu entre autres par les
deux membres présumés du flnc charles
pieri et felice tomasi qui totalise pour
sa part 5 ans et 7 mois de préventive
pour des faits qu'il nie avoir commis
l'assassinât d'un gendarme
le 11 février 1982 tomasi et pieri qui
se retrouve dans le box avec leurs
accusateurs josette maracini le
troisième homme du commando
un procès attendu également par les
corses qui savent que la paix civile
qu'ils connaissent depuis plus de quatre
mois est tributaire du verdict de ce
procès ce matin les seuls échanges ont
concerné la composition de la cour
d'assises spéciale pas de jury populaire
mais sept magistrats comme lors du
procès de georges ibrahim abdallah cet
après midi deux heures et demie de
suspension pour s'inquiéter de l'absence
de témoins un docteur corse c'est en
effet lui même délivré un certificat
médical pour se porter pâle une lenteur
et une prudence qui témoigne s'il en est
besoin que ce procès a une dimension
politique
une dimension politique qui se
confirmera en principe demain par le
témoignage de deux nationalistes léo
battesti le docteur edmond simeoni
ap tous deux comme témoin 2
faut rendre le service militaire plus
juste 30 % des jeunes en âge d'être
incorporé ne font pas leur service il
faut ramener cette proportion à 20%
c'est l'ambition du ministre de la
défense jean pierre chevènement qui
était l'invité de notre journal de 13
heures et qui voudrait développer
certaines mesures comme le report à 24
ans de l'âge d'incorporation des jeunes
qui font des études supérieures
le nobel de médecine 88 a été attribué
aujourd'hui par le jury de stockholm à 3
anglo saxons qui travaille depuis des
années n'ont pas à la recherche pure
mais à la mise au point de médicaments
qui traitent déjà toutes sortes de
maladies courantes de l'ulcère au cancer
et aux maladies virales à la lhabouz
le britannique james blake est à
l'origine du médicament le plus prescrit
de l'histoire l'asim et y dîne dans le
traitement de l'ulcère d'estomac
c'est ici dans cette partie en jaune de
l'estomac que les cellules vont dans
certaines conditions sécréter trop
d'acides chlorhydrique trop c'est à dire
suffisamment pour détruire la muqueuse
gastrique en 1972 black comprend enfin
pourquoi sur cette cellule des
récepteurs vont capter les molécules
d'histamine c'est le déclenchement de ce
nuage blanc le signal libération d'acide
dans l'estomac
la parade du chercheur britannique est
presque simple fabriquer un médicament
qui neutraliseraient les récepteurs de
la cellule et empêcherait donc la sortie
d'acide vers l'estomac une espèce de
système de fausses clés que blake avait
déjà utilisé en cardiologie dans la mise
au point du premier bêta bloquants un
système qui offre encore de nombreux
espoirs en thérapeutique
une réponse que durant ma vie ça a été
une révolution mais nous commençons à
peine à savoir manipuler la biochimie et
je crois que maintenant nous sommes
conscients que ça nous pouvons le faire
et nous continuerons à le faire de mieux
en mieux
baroin gertrude et l'yonne et georges i
ching
les deux autres lauréats du prix nobel
de médecine sont parvenus à bloquer les
messages de certaines cellules des
messages codés de leur patrimoine
héréditaire que les chercheurs
américains au plus brouillés grâce à de
nouvelles molécules
ces molécules aujourd'hui sont devenus
des médicaments contre la goutte le
cancer ou même l'herpès
alors on espérait cette année un nobel
français mais il faut bien dire que la
récompense ainsi décerné à une forme de
recherche directement soucieuse
d'applications pratiques et industriels
cette récompense souligne l'un des
problèmes graves de la recherche en
france
le divorce dans ce domaine entre la
recherche et l'industrie
jean daniel flaysakier le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'en matière de
découverte de médicaments la recherche
française est loin de faire la course en
tête
nous sommes passés en 20 ans du 2e au
10e rang mondial
et comme partout l'argent est le nerf de
la guerre quant à laboratoire français
investit 10 francs dans la recherche à
laboratoire allemand ou japonais en
investi 20 et à laboratoire américain
investit 100 francs outre ce manque de
moyens le mal français à d'autres causes
notre recherche est beaucoup trop tourné
vers le fondamental est beaucoup moins
hélas vers les applications pratiques
la plupart des scientifiques afin de
montage c'est comme ça ont travaillé sur
ce point occupé des applications quand y
avait une application pour mieux et puis
il ya la rigidité des structures un
universitaire américain peut
parfaitement partir deux ans dans un
laboratoire pharmaceutique privée et
retrouver ensuite son poste à la faculté
en france cela relève de l'impossible il
faut faire un choix
c'est ce qu'a fait un jour pierre simon
il était professeur à la faculté de
médecine de la pitié salpêtrière
il est aujourd'hui directeur de
recherche à la sanofi croit que
l'industrie pharmaceutique a une chance
dans sa recherche
c'est que à l'heure actuelle il n'est
possible de faire de grandes découvertes
grandes découvertes au plan économique
que si ce sont des beaux si de grandes
découvertes aux plantes de la peur pour
le malade et que par conséquent si on
peut concilier l'utile et l'agréable
le très bien et c'est vraiment ce qui
existe de plus en plus donc moi j'ai pas
je pas le sentiment d'avoir vraiment
rendu mon âme au diable
depuis quelques années le nobel de
médecine récompense des travaux qui ont
eu des applications médicales très
rapide des travaux qui ont été financés
par des compagnies américaines suisse ou
britanniques
la france a aussi de grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques de grande équipe de
recherche
le tout est qu'ils arrivent à se
rencontrer pour la première fois depuis
la création de l'état d'israël son
président henri merzoug est arrivé cet
après midi à paris une visite d'état de
cinq jours
la france est pour vous un pays ami et
nous espérons que la paix puisse avancer
a déclaré en l'accueillant tout à
l'heure le président mitterrand en
israël où les élections législatives se
prépare dans un climat alourdi par les
troubles dans les territoires occupés
shimon peres le chef du parti
travailliste a laissé entendre un
charles enderlin que des contacts
étaient en cours avec la jordanie
c'était lé 31 juillet dernier hussein de
jordanie se retirait du processus de
paix est confiée à l'ol paie l'entière
responsabilité des palestiniens de
cisjordanie et de gaza
un coup dur pour les travaillistes
israéliens qui comptait se présenter
devant les électeurs en proposant des
négociations avec le souverain hachémite
mais shimon peres n'a pas dit son
dernier mot
de bonnes sources parti travailliste
nous avons appris que des négociations
secrètes se sont déroulées avec
l'entourage du roi hussein
le souverain aurait accepté de revenir
sur sa décision de rompre avec les
palestiniens des territoires
les travaillistes espère qu'il annoncera
très bientôt son intention de négocier
si shimon peres gagne les élections
l'initiative qui risque de brouiller
toutes les cartes de la campagne
électorale en israel en algérie c'est
maintenant le temps des procès pour les
prévenus interpellés lors des émeutes
des quinze derniers jours
la procédure suivie et la procédure
normale affirme le ministre algérien de
la justice qui ne donne aucun chiffre
d'arrestations poursuite mais des
audiences spéciales sont organisées pour
aller plus vite il n'y a pour les
peuples d'europe d'autre avenir que
l'union cette phrase de jean monnet
michel rocard l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
à paris en rendant hommage à l'un des
pères fondateurs de l'euro
à l'occasion du centenaire de la
naissance de jean monnet le premier
ministre a inauguré une plaque sur
l'immeuble qui a abrité pendant 20 ans
le comité d'action pour les états unis
dans il faut se préparer aux rigueurs de
l'hiver c'est le souci des organisateurs
des restaurants du coeur fidèle à la
mémoire de coluche qui ont présenté tout
à l'heure leur campagne d'action
emmanuel vanier
l'enfoiré n'est pas mort dans le coeur
de tous ces artistes date de lancement
de la prochaine campagne des restos du
coeur le 21 décembre 22 millions de
repas distribués par sept mille cinq
cents bénévoles
c'était l'an dernier pour l'hiver
prochain ces artistes et bien d'autres
ont décidé de verser la recette de l'un
de leur gala à l'association de coluche
demain la loi coluche revue par michel
charasse ministre dû budget sera
présenté à l'assemblée nationale elle
prévoit de faire bénéficier les
donateurs de 50% de réductions fiscales
pour les dons allant jusqu'à 400 francs
aide à toute détresse
atd quart-monde commémorait aujourd'hui
le premier anniversaire du dépôt d'une
plaque sur le parvis de la liberté des
droits de l'homme au trocadéro
sur cette plaque une phrase du père
brzezinski décédé l'an dernier
là où des hommes sont condamnés à vivre
dans la misère les droits de l'homme
sont violés s'unir pour la faire
respecter est un devoir sacré atd quart
monde va relancer prochainement ses
actions des deux plus démunis trois cent
cinquante mille familles en france
vivent dans la misère
depuis 36 heures une femme et ses trois
enfants sont barricadés dans cette
maison de souvigny en sologne dans le
loir et cher
hier matin annie graulhet a tiré un coup
de feu sur son ex mari qui venait
chercher son fils pour la journée
jean-claude dupuis a été grièvement
blessé annie graulhet refuse ce droit de
visite
elle conteste même la paternité de
jean-claude dupuis elle exige la
modification de l'état civil de son fils
depuis hier matin elle menace de tuer
ses trois enfants et de se suicider si
elle n'obtient pas satisfaction
les vivres en pagaille des trouvailles
saugrenue mais aussi une véritable
industrie très rentable est vital pour
notre commerce extérieur le salon de
l'alimentation été inauguré ce matin à
villepinte par le premier ministre élise
avait été gelée nous propose des
nouveautés 88
voici la nouille du bicentenaire une
guillotine le salon de l'alimentation
s'est mis à l'heure de la révolution il
propose aussi la bastille ou le bonnet
phrygien
dans un autre registre voici un fromages
frais allégés enrobées de chocolat à
manger plutôt dessert suivi peut-être
d'un yaourt aux fruits présenté en
cornet comme une glace pour
confectionner des gâteaux plus besoin de
casser les oeufs on peut utiliser jaunes
blancs ou mélange des deux sous forme
déjà liquide a étalé facilement sur le
pain le beurre frigo tartinables c'est
ainsi qu'on l'appelle sans additif mais
grâce à une fabrication différentes
il ne dure si jamais quant aux morceaux
de sucre il change de format quatre fois
plus petit que les autres il apporte
quatre fois moins de calories grâce à la
présence d'un édulcorant l'aspartame et
puis il ya ceux dont on parle beaucoup
mais qu'on hésite à nous montrer les
plats cuisinés sous vide qui vont
peut-être bientôt supplanter les
surgelés
on les teste pour l'instant
on peut trouver à la fois des produits
finis peu ou des produits répartis dans
des sachets ensuite mis dans un bois
tâches qui sont puis séparément et qui
ensuite sont partis d'une cuisine
d'assemblage qui est également quelque
chose qui intéresse le consommateur
aujourd'hui dans la mesure sont les
produits qui sont préparés très vite et
gagner du temps est une des contraintes
de notre époque pour les accompagner on
peut choisir le premier vin sans alcool
d alcoolisées par distillation airs et
aromatisées il coûte 12 francs la
bouteille
à consommer sans modération ce que l'on
voit ce que l'on mange comment on vit en
france en 88 et moi et moi et moi c'est
le thème de la marche du siècle de jean
marie cavada dans quelques minutes sur
antenne 2 mais d'abord très vite les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour
vincennes demain soir le 16 le 11 13 le
douce le dise le 4 le 8 et le 2 voilà à
minuit henri sannier vous présentera
notre dernier journal demain 6h45 ranger
zabel invité des 4 vérités madame
barzakh dans un instant laurent cabrol
pour le temps merci d'avoir suivi ce
journal à demain 20h très bonne soirée
à